the new york times facing backlash in
the debate over free speech in america
it ran an article urging that the biden
administration create a quote
truth commission and appoint another
quote reality czar to combat this
information
now the wall street journal editorial
board hit back hard they dismissed the
idea as a crackdown on political speech
in an editorial titled liberalism's
ministry of truth
academics and the progressive press mall
state media controls
so jesse let me begin with you and say
we know the government can't limit free
speech that's that'd be unconstitutional
but there is tremendous concern about
you know violent
rhetoric death threats and the like what
would you do
well greg gets death threats constantly
and he seems fine
listen republicans win elections 2-1
what if trump runs in 2024 and wins does
he get his own truth commission
that'll be fun we get to pull up all
these fake news anchors from cnn and
msnbc
and they have to testify live on fox of
course
about how they booted some report about
how those reports were just hacks
we could bring up the washington post
fact checker and ask him why he spins
for democrats
what are we going to have let's see
kellyanne conway
she could be the reality czar
alternative facts
we can play that game too on does she
get a jet like john kerry the climate
czar
i mean come on you don't ever want to
merge truth
with the state who's done that uh last
time i checked it was soviet russia
and communist china we don't want to go
down that road
greg yesterday when we were talking i
think we came to some agreement about
big tech because you don't like the idea
that they would silence
some people so what would you do in
terms of
cracking down on excesses of big tech
well first of all i you have to
understand what what the new york times
is suggesting it's a feeble mirror image
of trump confronting fake news trump
would just call it out
almost at every opportunity which is how
you do it because
as you know it's subjective one person's
fake news
is another person's true news that is
why leftism is so
scary because what they do is they
attach objective consequences
to subjective beliefs all right so this
turns out to be kind of an autocratic
hall monitor version of censorship
now you don't have to censor anybody you
could just call them out on it
but that's not enough when you when
democrat liberals and leftists get into
power
then it's their turn to turn the screws
on their critics
instead of just calling them out they
wish to silence them i have no interest
in silencing anyone
i want to hear i want to hear the
dumbest idea i've ever heard sometimes i
do every day
but i want to hear it i don't i don't
think that they i don't i think you know
what uh what's his name
uh shoot i can't think of his name uh
the guy that got kicked off of youtube
jones alex jones
i see more of alex jones now than i did
when there was info
wars that's what happens when you
silence bad ideas
they just come out in other places
dana i was thinking back to tobacco and
i was thinking what did we do
when we were trying to deal with tobacco
as a public health issue and
for a lot of people the threats the
pornography
all that's going on online is a public
health issue
is it something that we could deal with
through public awareness how would you
deal with it
okay wait uh public health issue
uh no i don't think so i'm just trying
i'm like trying to
i don't i mean i i'm glad that we don't
have smoking in restaurants that's my
preference but i know that there are
still some people who strongly believe
that if you are a business owner and you
want to
allow smoking in your restaurant that
you should allow that um
i don't think that you can actually mix
up public health and free speech now i
agree like you can't yell
fire in a crowded theater but i also
don't think this is what this is about
um look i get i don't i don't like this
information either way
um and we know that that can be out
there but i think that the only way to
really deal with that is to have
more speech not less
all right degan do you agree um yeah
conservative
thought and speech causes cancer i'm
still trying to make that connection
in my head the
liberals get a pass from this censorship
censorship of thought and speech but to
greg's point i'm going to
just reiterate what he said earlier in
the show how much
wrongdoing and bad nefarious behavior
is being ignored because people are
worried about somebody
or 74 million people who voted for
donald trump the biggest problem are the
technology monopolies apple google
amazon and facebook because we now see
they have been co-opted by the
government so
it's not a clear violation of the first
amendment
but it's pretty damn close and they're
censoring conservatives because they
don't want to be regulated
i think the concern was over violence
and what we saw january
6th once we're done violence
is a health concern over the summer it's
a health concern believe me
25 people died over the summer health
concern i agree all right we have
we have i'm being told we have to go
folks i